SEE YOU TOMORROW NIGHT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUKCER CALRSON
TONIGHT."
AFTER TWO MONTHS OF WRITING AND
POLITICAL CHAOS THERE IS STILL
PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO CLAIM THIS
IS ALL ABOUT THE DEATH OF GEORGE
FLOYD AND BELIEVE IT OR NOT,
THERE ARE.
SOME OF THEM ACTUALLY BELIEVE
IT.
THE LIBERAL MOM WHO LIVES NEXT
DOOR TO YOU FOR EXAMPLE.
SHE IS PROBABLY ENTIRELY SINCERE
WHEN SHE LECTURES YOU ABOUT THE
SCOURGE OF POLICE BRUTALITY, SHE
MEANS IT.
WE ARE NOT JUDGING AND THAT’S
NOT SURPRISING.
MOST AMERICANS ARE NICE PEOPLE.
THEY ARE LITERAL AND INGENUOUS
AND THEY TEND TO TAKE CLAIMS AT
FACE VALUE BECAUSE I WANT TO
BELIEVE THE BEST.
BUT IN THIS CASE THEY ARE WRONG.
NONE OF WHAT YOU ARE WATCHING IS
ABOUT CIVIL RIGHTS.
VIOLENCE AND RACE BAITING ARE
THE ENEMY OF CIVIL RIGHTS.
WHAT YOU ARE WATCHING INSTEAD IS
A POWER GRAB.
THEY DON’T WANT YOU TO KNOW WHAT
YOU ARE DOING.
THEY ARE NOT LIKE YOU AT ALL.
WHEN NORMAL PEOPLE WANT
SOMETHING, THEY CAN BE
AGGRESSIVE BUT THE PROFESSIONAL
LEFT NEVER IS.
THEIR FIRST INSTINCT IS TO
MANIPULATE RATHER THAN PERSUADE,
AND THEY SAY PRECISELY THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT THEY MEAN EVERY
TIME.
THEY ACCUSE YOU OF THE CRIME
THAT THEY THEMSELVES ARE
COMMITTING.
IT MAKES YOUR HEAD SPIN AND
ARGUING WITH THEM IS POINTLESS.
THEY CARE ONLY ABOUT POWER.
IT’S PAINFUL TO SAY THIS AND IT
HURTS TO ADMIT THERE ARE PEOPLE
IN OUR COUNTRY WHO ARE LIKE THIS
BUT THERE ARE.
AND IF THEY HAVE MORE POWER THAN
EVER.
IF YOU NEED MORE EVIDENCE OF
THAT, BARACK OBAMA SHOWED UP AT
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS’ FUNERAL
TODAY AND OBAMA CLAIMS HE WAS
THERE TO EULOGIZE HIS FRIEND AND
THAT’S NOT TRUE AND THAT’S NOT
WHAT HE DID.
INSTEAD OBAMA GAVE A DIVISIVE
AND DEEPLY DISHONEST CAMPAIGN
SPEECH IN CHURCH.
IT IS PART OF WHAT HE SAID.
>> BY ENDING SOME OF THE
PARTISAN GERRYMANDERING SO THAT
ALL VOTERS HAVE THE POWER TO
CHOOSE THEIR POLITICIANS, NOT
THE OTHER WAY AROUND.
AND IF ALL THIS TAKES IS
ELIMINATING THE FILIBUSTER,
ANOTHER JIM CROW RELIC, IN ORDER
TO SECURE THE GOD-GIVEN RIGHTS
OF EVERY AMERICAN, THEN THAT’S
WHAT WE SHOULD DO.
>> Tucker: ’S HARD TO BELIEVE
THAT CLIP IS REAL BUT IT IS.
DOWN TO THE FAKE ACCENT,
MR. HAWAII GUIDE.
IMAGINE IF SOME GREASY
POLITICIAN SHOWED UP AT YOUR
LOVED ONE’S FUNERAL AND STARTED
THROWING AROUND STUPID PARTISAN
TALKING POINTS ABOUT SENATE
PROCEDURE.
CAN YOU IMAGINE?
YOU WOULD BE SHOCKED IF THAT
HAPPENED.
DESECRATING A FUNERAL WITH
CAMPAIGN SLOGANS?
WHAT KIND OF PERSON WOULD DO
THAT?
DEMOCRATS IN THE AUDIENCE DIDN’T
BLINK, THEY CHEERED.
IT ALL SEEMED NORMAL TO THEM AND
WHY WOULDN’T IT?
POLITICAL POWER IS THEIR
RELIGION.
IT’S NOT OUT OF PLACE, IT’S
THEIR RELIGION.
PEOPLE WHO POLITICIZE A FUNERAL
WILL DO ANYTHING AND THEY ARE
TRYING TO.
DEMOCRATS ARE WORKING
SYSTEMATICALLY TWO DISASSEMBLED
THE CORE INSTITUTIONS OF
AMERICAN LIFE BEGINNING WITH THE
FAMILY AND OF THE FAITH.
THEY ARE SUBVERTING THE COURT
SYSTEM IN OUR GOVERNMENT, THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THEY ARE NULLIFYING LAWS,
ATTACKING COURTHOUSES AND
WORKING TO ELIMINATE.
THEY SYSTEMATICALLY REPURPOSED
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
AND THEY ARE POSITIONED AS
POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
THEIR LEADERS HAVE CALLED TO
MAKE ALL THESE CHANGES
TOURNAMENT, PACKING THE
ELECTORATE ITSELF BY IMPORTING
TENS OF MILLIONS OF NEW VOTERS.
WHY ARE THEY DOING ALL OF THIS?
THEY TELL YOU IT’S TO MAKE THE
COUNTRY BETTER AND MORE JUST FOR
THE COUNTRY ISN’T IMPROVING AND
IT’S NOT MORE FAIR.
THEY ARE DOING THIS FOR ONE
REASON, TO ENSURE THEY HAVE
COMPLETE CONTROL OF THE
UNITED STATES.
WE ARE WATCHING IT HAPPEN RIGHT
NOW ALTHOUGH ALMOST NO ONE EVER
ADMITS IT AND THOSE WHO DO COME
CLOSE TO GETTING SHUT DOWN.
WE COULD TELL YOU STORIES.
SO HOW SHOULD THE REST OF US
RESPOND TO WHAT WE ARE SEEING?
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT
CONSERVATIVES FOR PEOPLE WHO
WATCH THE SHOW, WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT LITERALLY EVERYONE ELSE.
MODERATE, PEOPLE WHO DO CARE
ABOUT CIVIL LIBERTIES, AND THERE
ARE SOME OF THOSE.
IMMIGRANTS FROM ABROAD WHO CAME
TO THIS COUNTRY BECAUSE OF OUR
BILL OF RIGHTS ONLY TO WATCH IT
EVAPORATE ONCE THEY GOT HERE.
IN OTHER WORDS, EVERYONE WHO
FUNDAMENTALLY LOVES THIS COUNTRY
WHICH IS STILL MOST AMERICANS,
WHAT ARE PEOPLE LIKE THAT DOING
IN THE FACE OF THIS REVOLUTION?
IT’S SIMPLE.
DEFEND THE SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE.
THAT’S OUR JOB.
THE AMERICAN SYSTEM IS FLAWED,
NO ONE DOUBTS THAT.
BUT IT WORKS BETTER THAN ANY
OTHER SYSTEM IN HISTORY.
TEARING IT DOWN WILL NOT HELP,
AND IN FACT IT WILL BENEFIT ONLY
A FEW OF THE ONES PUSHING FOR IT
AND WILL CRUSH MILLIONS.
SO IF YOU CARE ABOUT THE
UNITED STATES, FIGHT FOR ITS
INSTITUTION.
THIS COUNTRY HAS SURVIVED ALMOST
250 YEARS THROUGH A CIVIL WAR.
LET’S KEEP GOING.
THE PRESIDENT THIS MORNING
VENTED HIS FRUSTRATIONS ON
TWITTER ABOUT POTENTIAL VOTER
FRAUD IN THE UPCOMING ELECTION
AND HE WROTE THIS.
WITH UNIVERSAL MAIL-IN VOTING,
NOT ABSENTEE VOTING WHICH IS
GOOD, 2020 WILL BE THE MOST
ACCURATE AND FRAUDULENT ELECTION
IN HISTORY, IT WILL BE A GREAT
EMBARRASSMENT TO THE
UNITED STATES.
WE DON’T KNOW IF THAT’S TRUE, WE
HOPE IT’S NOT, BUT IT COULD BE.
THEN, HE ENDED IT THIS WAY.
THE LADY ELECTION UNTIL PEOPLE
CAN PROPERLY, SECURELY AND
SAFELY VOTE.
DELAY THE ELECTION.
THAT WAS A HEADLINE ACROSS CABLE
NEWS TODAY AND WE SHOULD BE
CLEAR, THAT WILL NOT HAPPEN, THE
ELECTION WILL ALMOST CERTAINLY
TAKE PLACE IN NOVEMBER.
BUT AT THIS POINT IT’S PROBABLY
UNWISE TO SUGGEST CHANGING ALL
THE ELECTION, VOTER FRAUD OR
NOT.
TOO MUCH IS IN FLUX ALREADY AND
IT’S NOT ACCIDENTAL, IT’S BY
DESIGN.
A BEWILDERED POPULATION DEALING
WITH CHANGE FROM EVERY POSSIBLE
DIRECTION CANNOT FIGHT BACK, AND
THAT’S WHY THEY ARE DOING IT.
SO OUR JOB IS TO DEFEND WHAT WE
ALREADY HAVE AS A NATION AND TO